our first stop is just down the road at
Kensington Palace there is trouble
brewing between William Kate Harry and
Megan and we're uncovering all the
reasons behind their royal rift William
and Kate made their first public
appearance today since et broke news
that there has quote been some tension
between the Royal couples and now as
Harry and Megan prepare to leave
Kensington Palace for Windsor Castle new
rumors of a Megan vs. caked Feud it
appears that some of the British media
are beginning to turn on Megan
commenting on her Hollywood demands her
diva like behavior and the fact that
frankly she doesn't seem to treat her
staff very well a lot of the feud
speculation is fueled by a news story
that Kate was quote left in tears before
Megan's wedding it was a dress fitting
for Princess Charlotte who of course was
a bridesmaid it should have been a very
happy occasion I'm told that Megan was
rather bridezilla about the whole thing
and royal expert Katie Nichol says the
brothers are moving in different
directions Harry wants to be his own
person that is what I'm being told by my
sources he doesn't want to be in
Williams shadow he wants to live in the
countryside he wants to have the ability
to get out of the spotlight particularly
when this little baby comes along I
think it's really good we've got you
know 4 4 different personalities Harry
joked about the stress of working with
family back in February when the Fab
Four made its first official appearance
together working as family does have its
challenges of course there's everybody
had the felt that was laughing
but you know we we start together for
the rest of our lives
[Music]